MALE SPEAKER: What are
you about to show us?
RIA SYMONDS: Why 7 is
a happy number.
So let's start with
the number 7.
So let's square 7, because all
numbers like to be squared.
I'm sure that's the root
of all happiness.
So 7 squared gives us 49.
So I'm going to take each of
those digits and square those.
So 4 squared.
I'm going to add
them together.
So I get 16 plus 81 equals 97.
So let's square each of those.
81 plus 49.
That gives me 130.
Let's try again.
1 squared plus 3 squared plus
0 squared gives me 10.
One more iteration, and I
think we'll be there.
1 squared plus 0 squared
equals 1.
This makes my number
7 a happy number.
It's happy because it ends up
with 1, which 1 is your first
natural number.
It's the number all numbers
are based upon.
If it's different,
you won't get 1.
That means this number
will be a sad number.
It's not particularly
important.
It's just fun.